[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour le 7-8 europe le
magazine européen de la rédaction de tv
78 au sommaire de ce mois ci zoom sur la
compagnie parisienne la transe
planisphère depuis dix ans cette
compagnie aborde les sujets européens
sous l'angle des arts et de la scène
actuellement en résidence dans un lycée
de seine saint denis elle participe au
projet europe fiction où des jeunes sont
invités à réfléchir sur l'identité
européenne faire le procès de l'europe
pour parler du vieux continent avec
humour mais aussi seriez c'est
l'objectif de la pièce l'europe à la
barre interactive et ludique elle sera
jouée le 18 mars prochain à saint-ouen
pour en parler francesca festa chef de
projet européen pour le magazine café
babel sera notre invité il sera aussi
question d'actualité dans cette émission
un mois après l'entrée en vigueur du
break sic nous avons posé trois
questions à fiona bickford une
britannique qui vit dans les yvelines
depuis 26 ans et qui est en charge de la
publication du journal bilingue de
snippet dans le département elle nous
dira notamment son inquiétude pour les
plus jeunes de ses compatriotes
explorez des problèmes de société lourd
et parfois graves
via les arts de la scène c'est
l'ambition de la compagnie de théâtre
trans planisphère depuis sa résidence au
lycée albert-schweitzer ainsi à la
compagnie collabore avec plusieurs
théâtres d'outre-rhin et des jeunes
européens dans le cadre du projet europe
fiction objectif imaginer l'identité
européenne à travers la thématique de la
simplicité vaste sujet forcément pour y
parvenir trans planisphère bénéficient
des fonds européens et du soutien de la
région ile-de-france aussi reportage au
raincy donc en seine saint denis les
mêmes gestes se répète constamment dans
une chorégraphie préparée pas mal
beaucoup est ce que vous l'avez senti
dans l'énergie quand vous saccadé ça
vous donne une énergie
différentes ils sont une quinzaine de
jeunes lycéens étudiants ou en formation
à s'interroger depuis plusieurs semaines
sur le thème de la simplicité pour un
projet européen en binôme avec de jeunes
allemands ils ont décidé de s'appuyer
sur une chanson d'orelsan basique
ok je demande un secret de faire une
instru simple pour dire des trucs
simples ce que vous êtes trop simple les
choses deviennent simples quand on prend
l'habitude de les répéter qu'on les
intègre un petit peu comme un enfant qui
apprend à marcher en s'exerçant ça
devient de plus en plus simple et
français en fait bon faire une espèce de
2002 inspiré de la langue des signes
pendant que les allemands déclameront de
textes d'orelsan
le projet fiction associe cinq théâtres
de la ruhr en allemagne avec des
compagnies européennes des semaines de
réflexion et de répétitions permettent
de préparer le temps fort du projet un
camp d'été où les jeunes partagent et
échangent sur leur vision de l'europe
ça fait une interaction avec des gens
cool forcément tu n'aurais jamais
rencontrés avant et ça c'est que ça crée
des liens et intense et même les sujets
traités ces bains de sang mélangé les
spectacles la politique c'est cool on
s'en fiche des religions des des langues
mais on s'en fout de tout et ont fait
ensemble et on travaille ensemble on
crée un truc ensemble et voilà cinquième
plus chouette financé en partie par des
fonds européens europe fiction est l'une
des actions menées par trans planisphère
la compagnie parisienne interroge depuis
dix ans les problématiques européennes à
travers la création artistique crois que
le rôle de l'art c'est d'arriver à
donner un peu d'enchantement un peu de
plaisir de la création et j'espère de
d'encourager voilà que les citoyens
européens et les français en
l'occurrence puisque nous on travaille
beaucoup avec les français aussi à
s'approprier ces enjeux là mais de façon
créative de façon imaginative et
j'espère
positive et joyeuse de la joie elle ne
devrait pas en manquer lors du summer
campe 2020 d'europe fiction qui se
tiendra en août prochain dortmund 150
jeunes se retrouveront alors pour une
semaine qui s'annonce tout sauf simple
et basique du théâtre et des fonds
européens il en est aussi question avec
notre invité francesca festa bonsoir
vous êtes chargé de projet européen pour
le magazine participatif et multilingue
café babel on va évoquer ensemble une
drôle de pièce de théâtre qui sera jouée
à mi mars à saint-ouen dont vous êtes
partenaires de cette pièce
il s'agit de l'europe à la barre comme
son nom l'indiqué l'accusé dans cette
pièce atypique c'est l'europe et
l'objectif si j'ai bien compris c'est de
susciter le débat de parler d'europe des
sujets un peu fâcheux est lourd mais de
façon assez ludique au théâtre oui bah
justement les propos c'est vraiment
d'essayer de se citer l envie de parler
d'europe et des maîtres donc les
citoyens au centre du débat européen
tout ça se pare aux pièces participative
comme l'europe à la barre qui met sur
scène donc un faux procès à l'europe à
un procès où il y a aussi des vrais
témoigne qui sont appelés pour un
témoigné en défense de l'union
européenne et pour la soirée du 18 mars
à saint-ouen ou à l'auditorium du palais
de la région il y aura karima delli
eurodéputée de l'europe les verts et
nora hamadi journalistes de arte oui
vous vous disiez faux procès parce
qu'évidemment c'est une pièce de théâtre
mais avec des gens investis sur ces
sujets donc on est sur un moment loisirs
de loisirs mais assez sérieux tout de
même puisque on aura des vraies
informations on pourra vraiment juger
l'europe
oui absolument les buts au final ce
n'est pas deux accusés vous défendre
l'union européenne les buts au final
c'est dé donner au spectateur la
possibilité d réfléchir aux enjeux
européens et des raies m donc les
citoyens au centre de tout cela
sa part du constat qu'aujourd'hui
l'europe est trop éloignée justement des
citoyens de ce qu'ils font l'europe
oui absolument sa part de ces constats
et des communs en fait taire et créent
du lien
avec les citoyens européens alors durant
cette soirée est ce qu'il ya des sujets
précis qui seront abordés ce qu'on les
connaît déjà ce que vous pouvez les
dévoiler ou alors c'est selon les
acteurs justement qui interviennent vous
disiez karima delli notamment
eurodéputés verts oui bah en fait la
soirée et il ya sûrement des sujets qui
sont des âmes déjà fixé par les
comédiens mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'en fait il ya une longue partie
d'improvisation selon les intervenants
donc les vrais témoins de karima delli
enora ahmadi elles seront amenées à
développer des sujets et les comédiens
et jouets vont donc avec avec les
invités et donc c'est vraiment parti
surprise parce que chaque chaque
représentation de l'europe à la barre
charge évolue en fonction aussi des
témoignages des spectacles différents en
tout cas c'est une pièce différente à
chaque fois c'est dire que si on a déjà
assisté alors pas la barre puisque c'est
un spectacle qui est une pièce qui est
qui existe depuis trois ou quatre ans
désormais on peut y assister
est-ce que c'est devenue aujourd'hui
essentielle ce genre de rendez vous pour
parler d'europe on sait que l'europe
c'est un sujet très lourd vous vous vous
le côtoyer tous les jours dans votre vie
est-ce que c'est nécessaire d'avoir
aussi ses moments de ludique de partage
et de rendre les choses un peu moins
complexe
absolument parce que là on image de
l'union européenne qui est très éloigné
très compliqué à décortiquer
alors qui est grâce à une pièce de
théâtre henry met donc en humanise à
nouveau l'unioneuropéenne et c'est de la
porter sur scène
tout en lui faisant un procès mais c'est
ludique c'est un pièces pointues c'est
drôle ça permet de passer un bon moment
aux spectateurs que finale bat sort de
la salle s'est dit d'accord c'est
effectivement j'ai pris une heure quinze
pour réfléchir à nouveau à nouveau sur
ce que c'est d'être européen qu'est ce
que ça l'union européenne aujourd'hui
comment comment faire avec et on apprend
beaucoup de choses et d'ailleurs
l'europe à la barre était passé dans les
yvelines c'était au mois d'avril dernier
à saint germain en laye parler d'europe
c'est aussi ce que vous faites on va
parler cette fois ci de cave et pavel
c'est ce que vous faites avec café babel
c'est un un journal participatif et
multilingue vous parler des sujets
européens pour les jeunes
oui exactement c'est un magazine
européen qui existe depuis presque vingt
ans c'est multi langues
bakiev est belle c'est avant tout aussi
on communauté c'est une communauté des
journalistes de photographes des
vidéastes de toute europe qui
participent au à la création de
nouvelles la narration européenne donc
café babel c'est aussi une plateforme en
ligne ou des jeunes journalistes sont
accompagnés et encadrés par deux
journalistes professionnels et café
babel ça permet aussi de parler d'europe
aux jeunes générations
donc d'où le partenariat avec les têtes
de l'art qui sont l'association à la
base de l'europe à la barca ce sac ou
les deux ça coulait de source est ce que
ça veut dire qu'il y aura des par
exemple des des participants à la vie de
café babel qui seront aussi acteur
durant le l'europe à la barre du 18 mars
alors pas de scoop vous par exemple dont
on a vu sur scène c'est sûrement
n'allait public pas sur scène mais il ya
où notre ancien directeur france a
family qui a déjà participé en version
précédente de leurs apps à la barre oui
et on précise que évidemment café babel
c'est un site participatif tout le monde
qui s'intéresse au sujet européen peut
vous contacter pour pour y participer
un mot encore sur sur sur cafebabel ça
existe depuis 20 ans vous le disiez ça
s'adresse à tous les jeunes puisque
c'est multilingue
ce n'est pas qu'en français en italien
longuet oui c'est traduit en six langues
donc ça c'est vraiment notre notre pari
c'est celui de pouvoir diffuser de
l'information sur la vie et européennes
sur ce que celle l'europe dans la vraie
vie à de la generala jeunes générations
en différentes langues donc chaque art
article où chaque vidéo est traduit en
plusieurs langues européennes et donc
café babel et partenaires de l'europe à
la barre au mois de mars prochain pour
plus d'information pour ceux qui
souhaitent peut-être porter un jugement
sur l'europe la voir sur le banc des
accusés au théâtre c'est notamment sur
europe point idf.fr pour s'inscrire est
le rendez vous c'est le 18 mars à
saint-ouen dans l'auditorium vous disiez
de la région ile de france
merci francesca effet stades est revenue
sur notre plateau je rappelle que vous
êtes chef de projet pour le magazine
européen café babel merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
plus symbolique qu effectif pour le
moment le break site est entrée en
vigueur le 31 janvier dernier européens
britanniques ont désormais jusqu'au 31
décembre prochain pour décider de leur
nouvelle relation
les négociations s'annoncent of
forcément compliqué en quelques mois
seulement elle inquiète aussi les
britanniques c'est le cas par exemple de
fiona pickford fondatrice et rédactrice
en chef du journal bilingue de snippets
cette britannique vit dans les yvelines
depuis 26 ans
nous lui avons posé trois questions
justement sur ce break site
regardez je suis triste pour mon pays je
me sens au rpm également britanniques
franchement je pense que c'est pas bon
pour le pays c'est une auto en arrière
sami ignol progrès qu'on a fait depuis
qu'on est con et est membre
de l'union européenne
je suis optimiste parce que les
britanniques sont toujours optimistes
je suis optimiste parce que j'habite ici
ma vie est ici depuis 26 ans maintenant
normalement les choses vont bien se
passer
mais pour le royaume uni ça va être
difficile
ça dépend de l'accord qui qu'ils ont
faim c'est les enfants quand qui vend
cadre sûrement parce que la libre et de
la libre de liberté de circulation les
libres d'échanger tous à la possibilité
d'aller travailler n'importe où en
europe
ça va y vont perdre un set up et unity
où ça va être plus difficile de toute
façon que que ça a été en angleterre les
gens s'inquiètent parce que ils ont ils
avaient l'habitude faire les vacances de
voyager beaucoup très facilement
ils sont tristes de perdre ses liens
avec l'europe
j'ai entendu parler d'un politicien
placement longue et elle qui a dit ben
oui dans le futur dans l'avenir immédiat
royaume uni va rester en dehors de
l'europe mais dans 20 ans on peut
se rapprocher
on est plus proche d'europe que tu as
manqué aux états unis le bric site qui
était évidemment en toile de fond d'un
déplacement très remarqué il ya quelques
jours dans les yvelines les trois
présidents des institutions européennes
ursula von der leyen
charles michel et david sassoli
respectivement les présidente de la
commission du conseil et du parlement
européen se sont rendus dans la maison
de jean monnet à bazoches sur guyonne
ils ont profité de cette rencontre pour
échanger sur les défis auxquels fait
face le continent
ils ont évoqué aussi l'avenir de l'union
européenne une conférence sur l'avenir
de l'europe doit d'ailleurs débuter à
partir du 9 mai prochain à l'occasion de
la journée de l'europe et les 70 ans de
la déclaration de robert schuman
déclaration connu pour être l un des
événements fondateurs de la construction
européenne on termine cette émission
avec notre rubrique chez nos voisins en
partenariat avec radio sensations durant
cette période rythmée notamment par le
salon de l'agriculture à paris
nous avons comparé les chiffres et les
moyens mis en place pour lutter contre
le gaspillage alimentaire en europe
alors qu'en france ce sont près de 10
millions de tonnes de nourriture encore
consommables qui sont à gaspiller
parents qu'en est il chez nos voisins
réponse d'olivier jeune lex du centre
d'information d'europe direct de saint
germain en laye on estime que 20 % de la
nourriture produite dans l'union
européenne est gaspillé ou perdus le
gaspillage alimentaire avoisine les 80 8
millions
tonnes par an ça fait en moyenne 173 kg
par habitant en france le gaspillage
alimentaire avoisine les 136 kg par an
et par habitant
malte la roumanie et la slovénie sont
les trois pays dont les habitants gâche
le moins de nourriture
un peu plus de 70 kg par habitant ce
sont les pays bas qui bat tous les
records de gaspillage alimentaire avec
541 kg de nourriture gaspillée chaque
année devant la belgique avec 345 kg et
chypre avec 3 127 kilos d'ici 2030 les
pays bas veulent diviser par deux la
quantité de nourriture jetée à la
poubelle
en supprimant par exemple les dates de
péremption sur le riz le café ou encore
les pattes en france depuis 2007 une loi
oblige les supermarchés de plus de 400
mètres carrés à rechercher un
partenariat avec une association d aide
alimentaire pour lui céder ses invendus
au lieu de les jeter ou de les détruire
en italie une loi était adoptée en 2016
pour faciliter les démarches
administratives qui encadre les dons
d'aliments par les agriculteurs les
industriels du secteur et les
commerçants ils peuvent ainsi bénéficier
d'allégements de taxe concernant les
ramassages des ordures s'ils confient
les excédents alimentaires à des
organisations caritatives en norvège
plusieurs initiatives ont vu le jour les
aliments qui approche de la date de
péremption sont vendus moins chers de
nouvelles étiquettes ont aussi vu le
jour certains fabricants utilisent
désormais l'indication meilleur avant au
lieu de à consommer avant les
commerçants sont également encouragés à
cesser les promotions du style deux pour
le prix d'un ou trois pour le prix d'un
afin d'éviter la surconsommation et puis
une autre initiative une application
développée par une start-up danoise too
good to go trop bon pour être jetés en
français à démarrer en 2015 au danemark
et ne cesse de conquérir l'europe
on la trouve notamment aux pays-bas en
grande-bretagne en france en belgique en
allemagne en suisse en italie ou encore
en norvège cette application permet
notamment aux commerçants de proposer
leurs invendus du jour à des prix
réduits
c'est la fin de ce set 8 europe merci de
l'avoir suivi rendez vous le 27 mars
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
elle d'ici là à cette émission et ses
différents modules sont à retrouver en
replay sur notre site et v60 18 points
comme et nos applications également
merci à tous et à très vite sur tv 78
[Musique]